l'essor prêché autant est en finale de
la coupe de martinique demain on
organise les derniers détails et sylvain
massé un bar vous paierez le transport
des joueurs location de salles le
dernier entraînement aura lieu ce soir
sur ce stade
[Musique]
un stade où les joueurs s'entraînent
quatre fois par semaine
cela suffira-t-il face à l'essor le
golden laguiole deuxième du championnat
de martinique
titré à chaque saison des moyens
financiers et humains bien supérieur aux
petits clubs de la petite commune du
nord
mais dans l'histoire les petits ont déjà
battu des grands on était passé là sinon
il va pas eu le stade 500 et goliath
donc il était passé mais bon on fait
savoir
l'essor precious a en effet donné
naissance à quelques champions wendy
renard jésus et joseph rose l'entraîneur
cultivent l'esprit du défi je crois que
sur le terrain on essaie de ne pas se
sentir petit club ça fait quand même 14
ans que le club est en arrière une même
si on n'a pas une grosse population mais
on a des joueurs qui sont talentueux
déjà durant talentueux donc avec eux on
a essayé de travailler puis on a un 6e
ce brin de chance qui nous permet d' qui
nous a permis de passer les étapes pas
un temps pour arriver jusqu'à la finale
alors mine
on y croit ou pas une chose est sûre
tout le monde est derrière les sorts à
faux à la bouille
ce sera à nous de nous de le voir au
théâtre ou fait pas cela il s'est très
très mal classés aux jo de la jeunesse
où étaient calées solène de bien ça fait
je crois trois finales de cette année en
quatre pour apporter pour l'emmener au
prêcheur
la dernière finale jouée par le prêcheur
remonte à une dizaine d'années
face au club franciscain l'essor avait
perdu 2 buts à 1
mais demain qui sait david vaincra
peut-être gaulle y est
[Musique]